die krokodil plant in corona hammer für
praxen und heime ohne impfung keine
anstellung ja das ist der plan die groko
fraktion haben sich gestern abend
überraschend einen nochmals geänderten
entwurf angeschaut der wurde vorgelegt
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
darin versteckt arbeitgeber in
bestimmten unternehmen und einrichtungen
sollen den impfstatus der beschäftigen
abfragen dürfen also kontrolle sind sie
geimpft oder nicht der impfstatus darf
dann so heißt es darin über die
begründung eines
beschäftigungsverhältnisses
oder über die art und weise der
beschäftigung entscheiden das heißt also
ganz klar wenn ich geimpft ist kann
gefeiert werden oder nicht angestellt
werden oder darf zumindest seinen beruf
nicht ausüben
das ist tatsächlich eine ganz neue
wendung der bisher wusste man ja zum
beispiel in schulen gar nicht offiziell
wer ist da im kollegium geimpfte oder
nichts süßes maja datenschutz und so
weiter also jetzt wird dort mehr
transparenz eingeführt und bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer bei uns im studio das
kann knallharte folgen haben für
kollegen die sich nicht impfen lassen
absolut das kann knallharte folgen haben
aber wir haben ja auch im vergangenen
jahr gesehen wie dramatisch die
situation in pflegeheimen gewesen ist
und wir haben ja auch zu recht in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten immer
wieder beklagt wie kann es eigentlich
sein dass nicht klar ist wie viele
lehrerinnen und lehrer sich
beispielsweise an schulen haben impfen
lassen also dass man eigentlich den
schülern permanent zumutet dass sie sich
testen lassen müssen aber das nicht klar
war vom lehrpersonal wie viele impfungen
hat eigentlich dort gegeben und nicht
und von daher kann ich mir durchaus
vorstellen dass man in berufen die mit
mit personen oder wo personen mit
wirklich gefährdeten menschen dann
zusammenarbeiten dass so was durchaus
sinn machen kann wird das jetzt zu
vielen kündigung führen glaubst du oder
wird das zu viel mehr impfungen führen
es wird mutmaßlich zu mir im funk führen
dass es um das auch noch mal klar zu
sagen ich bin dagegen eine impfpflicht
ganz generell aber wir stehen natürlich
fest und da muss man dann immer schauen
eine eine abwägung auch bevor man also
den druck auf kinder in schulen immer
weiter erhöht und ich weiß es selbst
weil ich schulpflichtige kinder habe
dieses permanente testen es ist schon
eine belastung da können wir als
mittwoch freitag können wir als
erwachsene drüber lächeln wenn wir
doppelt geimpft würde ich sagen wir
lassen uns nicht testen aber das ist
schon was also morgens immer zu wissen
habe ich die maske dabei ja heute ist's
wieder testtag das ist schon eine
extreme belastung und insofern glaube
ich es ist durchaus auch zu erwarten
dass sich lehrerinnen und lehrer impfen
genauso wie sich auch pflegepersonal
impfen lassen kann es geht ja auch muss
man hier noch mal ganz klar sagen also
um die menschen die in sensiblen
bereichen arbeiten also im pflegerinnen
und pfleger in kitas in schulen und du
sagst völlig zurecht jan dort menschen
auszusetzen risiken auszusetzen weil die
menschen die es sich zur aufgabe gesetzt
haben dort verantwortung zu tragen sich
dort zu kümmern dort ihren beruf
gefunden zu haben jetzt also die
auskunftspflicht dass ihr arbeitgeber
zumindest abfragen darf die
informationen einholen darf
[Musik]